welcome to this second piece of the Q&A
and Pastor rondes kit would you kindly
lead us in an opening prayer yes our
father in Heaven you've called us to do
a very important work we want to do it
well first cleanse our hearts from sin
Now Grant To Us in great measure the
spirit of truth that he may guide us
into truth dear God that the responses
we give may represent you and be a
blessing to those listening bless the
audience father I pray in Jesus name
amen amen our first question is why did
Jesus wait until he was 30 to begin his
ministry it could be that in the Jewish
system priests began their duties at the
age of 30 that's when he began the
duties it could be that could be one
reason why Jesus began his ministry even
though he was not a priest on the Earth
but he would ultimately be a priest in
heaven but it could be for that reason
the Jews began their Priestly duties at
the age of 30 so Christ began his public
Ministry at the age of 30 all right
thank you what are the fruits that we
are supposed to produce according to the
Bible Well the fruits are listed in
Galatians
52223 but the fruit of the spirit is
love joy peace longsuffering gentleness
goodness Faith meekness Temperance and
verse 23 ends this way against such
there is no law in other words the law
Lord does not condemn the fruits of the
spirit those are the fruits we're
supposed to produce and so when Jesus
told the disciples in John 158 here in
is my father glorified that you bear
much fruit those are the fruits there
are no other fruits we required to
produce but the fruits by the way notice
they call the fruits of the spirit not
the fruits of the person if you set out
to produce those fruits in your own
power you introduce yourself to
frustration they are produced by the
Spirit dwelling within you through
constant surrender they are the fruits
of the spirit only the spirit can
produce them in you but he must do that
from the inside which requires the
surrender of your life to God
constantly okay thank you how do we
worship one God when we have God the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit now
we worship one
God in Genesis 1:26 the Bible says and
God said let us make man in our image we
have our which is plural but we have
image which is singular so Father Son
and Holy Spirit have the same image it's
the same Divinity it's the same Essence
is the same God let us make man in our
image then you read verse 27 so God
created man in his own image so we have
his one of the group in verse 26 we have
have hour that's more than one one of
them actually did the creating because
verse 27 says so God created man in his
own image so we have plural in 26 we
have singular in 27 but it is always
image not images
image and so we have one Essence one
image one Divinity and we're dealing
with a subject that no human mind can
fully understand we must make that
admission whenever we discuss God the
moment you think you understand God
fully you're saying God is no longer God
but job 11:7 tells us can't thou by
searching find out God can't thou find
out the almighty un Perfection no one
can fully understand God you see and so
we dealing with a subject that's massive
but there are evidences in the Bible
that there are three persons but one
Essence one Divinity one
God so we baptized people name of the
father name of the son name of the Holy
Ghost but it's one name okay three
persons all right so praying to Jesus is
not contradictory to praying to God no
but Jesus said pray to God MH because
even though they equal they have
different functions it was Jesus who
came in human form not the father not
the Holy Ghost now Jesus in human form
was led by the Holy Ghost acts 10:38
Luke 4:18 Jesus said the spirit of God
is upon me he hath anointed me to preach
the gospel so he was led by the spirit
but at the direction of the father and
so God anointed Christ with the Holy
Ghost and with power we have all three
in Acts 10:38 God anointed Christ with
the Holy Ghost and with power we have
God the Father the Holy Ghost and we
have Christ they have different
functions and so Jesus says when you
pray say our father so he tells us pray
to the father now if someone prayers to
Jesus I offer no condemnation I don't
all I can tell the person Jesus said
pray to the father not the Holy Ghost in
John 17 when Jesus prayed the entire
chapter six times he said father father
father six times in John 17 not the Holy
Ghost father and so they are equal but
they have different functions when you
convicted of sin it is the holy ghost
that does that that's why the Bible says
grieve not the spirit of God not don't
grieve Jesus or the father even though
they grieve when we disobey but the
power that convicts us is the Holy
Spirit and the Bible says don't grieve
him Jesus tells us in Matthew 1231 uh to
32 you can blaspheme the son and be
forgiven don't blaspheme the Holy Ghost
there's no forgiveness so there's
separate beings separate
functions but one Essence one Divinity
one God okay that's as far as we can go
all right was Satan being thrown down
from heaven Revelation 12:9 literal or
symbolic Revelation 12 let's read from 7
to9 of Revelation 12 and there was war
in heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the dragon and the dragon fought
and his angels and prevailed not neither
was their place found anymore in heaven
verse n and the Great Dragon was cast
out that old serpent called the devil
and Satan which deceiveth the whole
world he was cast out into the Earth and
his angels were cast out with him in
Luke 10:18 Jesus told the disciples I
beheld Satan like lightning fall from
Heaven it was Christ who threw him out
it was a literal casting out of the
devil yes all
right someone asked by the way the same
God who cast Satan Out of Heaven Can
cast him out of your life all right
amen one asks I had a child with a
nonbeliever and currently I'm dating a
Believer okay should I marry the one I
had a child with or the one I'm
currently dating I don't mean to be
harsh but I have to be blunt you should
not have been involved with the
unbeliever in the first place whoever
you are God loves you so do I but you
should not now you cannot marry someone
simply because the woman has your child
or you cannot marry a man because he
fathered your child M you marry because
the person falls under the category that
God has recommended they must be of the
same faith not only of the same Faith
but other things must be in place before
you make a decision to enter into a
union that is supposed to last for life
you know we live live in an age where
people divorcees though it's a it's a
sport but marriage is designed for life
and so you do not marry her simply
because he has your child don't add one
wrong to another you marry someone of
the same Faith 2 Corinthians
6:14 what be not unequally y together
with unbelievers what Fellowship have
righteousness with unrighteousness what
communion have light with Darkness it's
you don't do that yes you have to take
care of that child yes you must because
you're a father of the child but you
don't go marry her just because she had
your
child a child is no justification for
marriage it must be according to God's
Will and God's plan in his Bible so do
not marry her just because she had your
child and she's an unbeliever marry a
Believer I mean a genuine believer not
just someone who sits in a Pew a genuine
believer who lives according to the
principles of righteousness all right
but as I said take care of that child if
is still yours and God loves that child
okay does God
laugh let's go to Psalm 2 I almost did
not answer that question but I thought
let me answer it does God laugh we go to
Psalm 2 we read from verse one of we'll
go to 1 to 4 of Psalm 2 and discover if
God lastes wherefore do the Heathen rage
and the people imagine you can read for
us a vain thing while do then the
Nations rage and the people plot a vain
thing the kings of the earth set
themselves and the rulers take counsel
together against the Lord and against
his anointed saying let us break their
Bonds in pieces and Cast Away their cord
now listen to four he in the heavens
shall laugh at them mhm the Lord shall
hold them in yes so the Bible say is God
laughs MH when the final judgment is
poured out something will come out of
him some expression that looks like
laughter now God does not make fun of
people but that verse say he that sits
to Heaven shall laugh at them
mhh sometimes I remember my past sins
and also we're made in the image of God
mhm so the capacity to laugh yeah
perhaps exists with God as well all
right all right next is does sometimes I
remember my past sins and I really feel
bad thinking that God is still angry
with me what should I do you believe
what God has told you we must believe
God's word not base our spiritual lives
on how we feel because feelings change
with the weather the Bible tells us
clearly 1 John 1:9 if we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness now if you don't believe
that you are effectively calling God a
liar by not believing his word there are
many people perhaps listening to me now
who are walking around with a burden of
guilt because they have not accepted
God's forgiveness God has not called you
to forgive yourself only God can forgive
sin you cannot forgive yourself
forgiveness is what God does forgiveness
of sin you can tell a person okay I
don't hold it against you but to remove
Sin from the soul to remove guilt only
God can do that and God has promised I
will forgive you L's a beautiful passage
in the Bible let's go to Jeremiah
Jeremiah chapter 3 we shall read 12 and
13 of Jeremiah chapter 3 listen to these
beautiful words and believe them read
for us my pastor only acknowledge your
12 13 12 133 go and Proclaim these words
toward the North and say return sliding
Israel says the Lord I will not cause my
anger to fall on you
for I am merciful says the Lord I will
not remain angry forever MH only now
notice the word only do what acknowledge
your iniquity that you have transgressed
against so God is saying look come to me
and
admit I'm wrong only acknowledge come to
God and say father ah I stole that money
I am wrong forgive me Father I lied I I
am wrong in other words as we say in
United States come clean MH come clean
when a policeman points a gun at you you
throw both hands up God say throw your
hands up and say okay God you got me
you've I am wrong it's hard for the
carnal nature to say I am wrong and so
God says only
acknowledge your iniquity that you've
transgressed against the Lord and you do
that he forgives you and he forgets
right but we don't forgive people you
see so we throw that attitude upon God
and we assume God does not forgive but
God forgives he loves to forgive Micah
7:18 he delighted in Mercy and the
greatest act of Mercy is forgiveness
based on the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
whoever that person is God has forgiven
you believe it accept it and live as
though you are forgiven don't walk
around with the sins you've
confessed so our duty is to confess and
believe exercise our faith that he has
forgiven us he does not lie
amen next we have uh if God deserves the
glory and praise based on not based on
our
feelings will he still get glorified if
we serve him unwillingly yes God can be
glorified if you serve him unwillingly
now you get no spiritual benefit but you
can unwillingly conduct a Bible study
and someone is baptized God gets the
glory but you receive no spiritual
benefit you see because the motiv ation
is important to God the motive why did
you do it that's why many people will
say in the Judgment did we not prophesy
in thy name and in thy name have cast
out Devils thy name done many wonderful
works then will I profess unto them
depart from me I never knew you ye that
work iniquity and so the motivation is
important but yes God can get the glory
from service rendered unwillingly but
the person who does it unwillingly is
not spiritually blessed
okay if Robben was the only one who was
merciful to his brother Joseph MH why
did Jesus come from the line of Judah
God can do whatever he wants the
question is if Reuben the oldest of Jo
Jacob's son was the one who showed Mercy
to Joseph and he told the brothers don't
kill him let's sell him into slavery God
didn't have to choose Reuben God does
whatever he wants Psalm 115:3 but our
God is in the heavens he hath done
whatsoever he pleased Daniel 4:35 but
all the in abits of the Earth are
reputed as nothing he doeth according to
his will in the army of heaven and among
the inhabitants of the earth and none
can stay his hand or say unto him what
doest thou you can't tell God what are
you doing God does whatever he wants he
is Sovereign now the the the practice in
the Bible was the first born was the the
the the favored son you see the first
born God went against that Noah had
three sons God chose Shem as the line
through which Christ would come the
oldest boy was J eth not Shem Abraham
Tia had three boys Abraham n and heran
Abraham was the youngest God chose
Abraham Isaac had two sons and in the
womb God chose the younger of the two in
the womb so we can't tell God what God
can do whatever he wants even it goes
contrary to human practices so the fact
that Reuben was the one who showed Mercy
to Joseph did not obligate God to choose
Reuben we cannot tell God what to do God
chose
Judah number four in the line of the
boys that were born to Jacob God does
whatever he wants and to add to that
would be to say Reuben was not sinless
either Reuben wasn't sinless no of
course neither was Judah but God chose
Judah he chose Judah M all right and by
the way to to to extend that the priests
were to come from Levi Christ our high
priest came from came from Judah not
Levi so God can go contrary to human
practices and still be right all right
what is the right age to start dating
and is it right to date while in college
and or
university depends on your age you're 14
and 15 what are you dating for I mean
your child when God put Adam and Eve
together he put a man and a woman he
didn't put a boy and a girl are you with
me he put a man and a woman not a boy
and a girl and so dating is not for
children dating is for those who are on
the edge of adulthood for instance you
know God has given us the number seven
is a number of perfection let me go slow
on this seven is the number of
perfection now the teenage years are
seven 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 you have
seven perfect years to learn to be an
adult and so my recommendation I have no
Bible verse my recommendation is in your
later teens you can think of dating 18
19 when you you spent some time learning
what it means to being adult then you
consider uh dat not 13 and 12 as is the
case people watch television and they
see 12 year olds with girlfriends and
every child wants a boyfriend every
little boy wants a
girlfriend you must have some level of
emotional maturity you see and other
forms of maturity to enter in a because
dating is designed to lead to marriage
it is not a recreational sport are you
with me dating is not a recreational
sport its purpose is marriage so if
that's not your purpose you shouldn't be
dating okay but when you towards the end
of that trial period of s years perfect
time to learn to be an adult you can
consider dating But as God desires and
guides all right and wisdom would would
also call for how do you balance School
in this case University with your dating
well you have to prioritize MH did I
come to University to date or did I come
to study MH you understand we must make
tough choices many years ago I counseled
in medical school and I would tell the
students all the time when you're in
medical school you must put on your md
glasses medical doctor here they are on
this L you have M that's Medical on this
land you have d That's doctor never take
them off so if someone were to say to
you let's go and play Let's go to a club
you say hold on you put on your glasses
through the lens of why you came you say
no if you take them off and lose your
focus you say yes to everything and so
if you're in school pursuing a degree
did you come to the university to date
no you came to study now a relationship
May develop yes but if you're led by God
God will take care of that but you're
there to study and that is your focus
and if dating interferes with your
studying you have to give up the dating
all right prioritizing is not easy
MH because you've got to leave your
feelings
out what's
important why am I at the school why I'm
in medical school why am at University
why am I paying teach why am I paying
tuition why my parents sacrificing so
much why and you keep this in mind all
right M okay next one is um should
teenagers over 18 think about leaving
the Seventh Day Advent no any age to
think of leaving the 7even of the church
if you study what we believe honestly if
you reason through the scriptures we
have a system of truth that is 100%
biblical don't leave whether you go over
18 or under 16 don't leave when the
disciples were leaving Christ in John
665 from that time 66 many of disciples
went back and walk no more with him and
Jesus said to the 12 will he also go
away Peter said Lord to whom shall we go
thou Hast the words of eternal life he
stayed and the 12 stayed because of what
Jesus
said your church should be chosen on the
basis of what the church teaches not the
size of the organ how LLY the choir
sings how many people speak in tongues
what does the church Preach is it
biblical don't leave your the 7day
Adventist Church and where are you
going okay what's your ages don't leave
all right next uh spiritual prophecy
questions um first one is what Len G
white books do you recommend on the
topics of the Holy Spirit and uh knowing
uh known sins and their consequences as
well as overcoming those sins I
recommend two books one steps to
Christ if there were no Bibles available
on this Earth no books at all of any
kind and I were given a choice to pick
one book to live with for the rest of my
life it would be steps to Christ the
other recommendation The Desire of Ages
those two books are the ones I recommend
highly to the person who paused the
question all
right what are the unfallen worlds
is this truth found in the Bible or just
in spiritual prophecy there are there's
a hint or hints in the Bible forance
Revelation
12:12 therefore Rejoice ye heavens and
the that dwell in them War to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea
for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knoweth
that he hath but a short time listen to
how the verse begins therefore Rejoice
ye heavens and he that dwell in them the
Bible consistently talks about Heavens
in job 1:6 now it was a day when the
sons of God came to present themselves
before the Lord there are clear
evidences in Scripture that they are
inhabitants of other worlds that meet
with God regularly and Satan came to
meet with him as the representative of
this Earth because Satan came also among
them also job chap 2:1 again there was a
day when these Representatives come so
we have evidence from the Bible that
there are worlds where people live who
have never sinned okay and if we're
faithful one day when Christ sets of
this new world we'll be able to visit
them and this is literal not symbolic
we'll be able to visit them
okay Ellen White says that every Act is
judged by the motive that prompts it
could you please elaborate what this
means let's go to Mark chapter 7 Mark 7
we read 20 to 21 listen carefully to The
Words of Christ then we'll go to Matthew
12 we'll read uh 34 33
3435 we're looking at Mark 7: 20 what
does verse 20 say and he said what and
he said what comes out of man that
defiles man okay now in other words
adultery comes out of
here hatred comes out of here pride
comes out of here it goes from the
inside out mhm even if You' never do it
physically you then because it comes out
of here this is where motives are and so
let's go to Mark let's go to to Matthew
12 let's read verse
33 let's Matthew 12:33 hear what that
verse said when we go to
34 1234 reads 33 33
MH either make the tree good and its
fruits its fruits good or else make the
tree bad and its fruit bad uhhuh for a
tree is known by its FR okay what it
produced Now read 34 brood of vipers how
can you be being evil speak good things
for out of out of the abundance of the
mouth speaks what comes from here
originates here what comes from here
originates here read verse 35 a good man
a good man out a good treasure treasure
of his heart brings forth good things
yes it this is the origin this is is way
M this is what determines the character
of an act why did now for instance
here's a man he's wealthy he gives $1
million to the church and all the church
members this amen amen they don't
understand he just wants his name on a
plaque you see God sees that and he gets
no spiritual benefit from God now God
will use the money the money is his but
that man gets no credit from God not
because his motive was wrong but no
human being can see that and so the
servant of the Lord tells us in Christ
object lessons page 316 paragraph 2
Every Act is judged by the motive why
did you do that why but that applies on
the earth you see when there's a crime
investigators search first for a motive
why did he the motive will determine the
the character of the ACT is it
manslaughter or first-degree murder what
was the motive he came to the house to
steal he struggled with the house owner
the house owner had a gun in the
struggle he took the gun and shot him
that's manslaughter now if he came to
the house with a gun he had a different
motive you see is more than theft and so
motive determines the quality of an act
and so we keep the Sabbath for the right
motive to glorify God we return a tith
for the right motive not so God will
give us money because God said do it to
glorify God everything we do what's the
motive the glory of God without
exception my good pastor all right thank
you very much is there a conflict
between 1 Timothy 4:3 and Ellen White's
teaching on health let's go to 1 Timothy
chter 4 verse3 we shall read from verse
1 of 1 Timothy chapter 4 now the spirit
speaketh expressly that in the latter
times some shall depart from the faith
you can pick it up from verse two verse
two speaking lies in hypocrisy having
their own conscience seared with now
listen to verse three forbidding to
marry commanding to abstain from foods
which God created to be received with
Thanksgiving by those who believe and
know the truth now read verse four for
every creature of God is good and
nothing is to be refused if it's
received with
Thanksgiving for it isif Sanctified by
the word of God and pray look at verse
three again that's why the Bible must be
read microscopically let's look at verse
three again forbidding to marry mhm and
commanding to abstain from Meats which
God hath created to be received with
Thanksgiving of whom by uh-huh those who
believe know the ah so we have a
restricted population now not the whole
world because the whole world does not
believe so Paul is condemning those who
forbid what God approves forbidding to
marry and commanding to abstain from me
which God hath created to be received
with Thanksgiving of them that believe
and know the truth you know the people
of God now when you read verse four for
every creature of God is good Every
Creature means every creature that God
created for his people in verse three
not everything that lives verse three
puts restrictions on verse four Every
Creature means every creature God has
created to be received with Thanksgiving
of those that believe and know the truth
not just the whole world and so so 1
Timothy 4:3 does not contradict the
counsel we have from the spirit of
Prophecy not at all all
right finally Why don't many Adventist
churches teach medical missionary work
well we don't know statistically how
many don't or how many do is just an
assumption the good person is making now
I would imagine many don't because it is
not studied and its importance is not
understood but you know in um
in her writings otherwi consistently
supports medical missionary work Christ
did more healing and good works for
people than he did preaching if you heal
me I'll listen to you are you following
me if I'm in pain don't tell me keep the
Sabbath get rid of my pain if I'm hungry
don't tell me let's sing hymns give me
food and so medical missionary work
meets the material needs of people so
that they become more more apt to listen
to The Gospel a starving man cannot
concentrate on the gospel a naked man
wants clothes not prayer he wants
clothes and so the medical missionary
work is absolutely
essential and the church needs to be
aware of that but no church can be
commanded to promote medical missionary
work and so medical missionaries should
not be frustrated because this church or
that church is not promoted do it where
you're able to do it do it individually
if you have the skill you do it
individually don't wait for the church
to tell you to do it because the church
didn't tell you sin you did that all by
yourself then you can by yourself make a
decision to reach out to people with
your knowledge and bless them but
churches really yes should promote
medical missionary work Christ was a
medical
missionary it's the way to reach people
whom you otherwise would not reach
because
it's the right arm of it's not the
gospel it's the right arm of the Gospel
you understand me yeah yes so I support
medical missionary work
100% is that it for today yes that's let
me just say to those who listening I
wish I could see you wherever you are I
really wish but I don't know where you
are but wherever you are the only
intelligent way to live your life is
based on Matthew 4:4 where Jesus said to
the devil man shall not live by bre
alone but by every word that proceedeth
out of the mouth of God live by this
teach it to your children apply it to
every decision you have to make if you
do this God will securely secure you not
only in this life but he will secure you
for the life to come I recommend to you
I urge you the word of God studied and
obeyed will produce in you the very
image and likeness of your savior God
bless you and may God put a double
blessing on your children my pastor I'm
always happy to be with you God bless
you and bless your ministry you too
let's pray amen Our Father in Heaven
we're honored beyond anything we can
deserve to speak for
you let your spirit take our efforts
dear God and make our words clearer to
those who heard bless every person who
listened bless every family
bless any Ministry that may benefit from
what we've done and let our efforts dear
God result in more people coming to know
Christ more people falling in love with
thus say the Lord with the truth which
sanctifies bless every country
represented by those who watched I pray
remind them that the most high ruleth in
the kingdoms of men keep us under your
care take care of us father save all of
us when you come I offer this prayer
from my heart in Jesus name name amen
amen amen